you're promoting the end of the road
World Tour and you swear I might have
you raise your right hand and swear on a
Bible that this is the end of the road
and so there's a sadness but also maybe
a joy right in this tour when is the
band going to officially end the tour
what what's the details December 1st and
2nd is Madison Square Garden those are
the last two shows of the band we're
we're finishing up where we started I
believe there's seven 17 shows uh before
that in the States look some people have
kind of snickered and said oh this end
of the road tour has gone on for years
yeah we lost two and a half years to
covid we would have been done already
um so this yes this is this is the end
when you come to see the show it's
awesome it's the most high-tech show out
there and yet it's clearly a kick-ass
Rock and Roll Show it's not Vegas it's
not um something that loses its balls so
to speak it's everything kissed just
amped up and ramped up so look we're
giving it everything we have but Gene
has said he thinks he'll cry during the
last show oh oh I'm sure I I kid around
a lot of uh men don't do that I'm sure
I'm gonna cry like a nine-year-old girl
whose foot's being stepped on absolutely
kiss was born on 23rd Street it's only
taken us 50 years to go play the final
shows 10 blocks away on 33rd Street
which is Madison Square Garden
hello